Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Lass uns mal wieder nach Europa fliegen.
Juhu.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 239 und nachdem in dieser Woche eigentlich schon,
was abgeliefert haben nehme ich das große Review zum Kongress und ein paar andere Themen wollen wir jetzt in die bereits angekündigte Spezial Serie eintauchen als ob sie Serie wird das wenn wir noch mal sehen aber heute haben wir auf jeden Fall einen Spezial,
und begrüßen zunächst einmal unser Gast auf der anderen Seite nämlich Julia Julia Räder Hallo.
Oder du bist wahrscheinlich da wo man dich vermutet in Brüssel.
Maja na ja wenn ich nicht in Straßburg bin.
Wenn du nicht in Straßburg bist aber das ist ja eher die Ausnahme,
ja und wir wollen heute mal so ein bisschen EU Perspektive Nachtanken hierbei Logbuch Netzpolitik und natürlich insbesondere auf deine dein großes Schlachtfeld Urheberrechts eingehen und was daran noch so alles.
Dran hängt ja aber so an sich viel bist du so erstmal ins neue Jahr gekommen.
Ja total super also ich habe den neuer Silvesterabend auf einem hohen Berg verbracht ohne Internetempfang mitten in einer Wolke das war total entspannt und deshalb,
gehe ich jetzt auch irgendwie mit Energie.
Wassertage der Cloud.
Genau.
Man hört immer häufiger davon nur dieses irgendwie total Entzugsprogramm irgendwie das vielleicht auch.
Ja das ist doch einfach irgendwie.
Ja ein wichtiges Gegengewicht der sich GEMA irgendwie dann Bananen oder so weil ich weiß nicht ich arbeite die ganze Zeit mit meinem Kopf schwirrt Technologie und so weiter und ja das passiert halt wenn man sein Hobby zum Beruf machen dass man sich neue Hobbys suchen,
genau das Gegenteil.
Hobby als Beruf er genau also bist ja irgendwie auch echt ein Pulli Tanki geworden wie ist denn wie lange bist du jetzt schon EU-Abgeordnete.
Also im Mai sind 4 Jahre die Legislatur sind 5.
AOK Endspurt sozusagen also hoffen wir mal dass es da für dich die Möglichkeit gibt deinem Hobby auch weiterhin zu frönen so aber das ist ja noch mal ein anderes Thema aber mir war es denn so bisher.
Ja also es ist auf jeden Fall extrem aufregend und Nerven auf deinem die ganze Zeit also ich glaube wenn man das jetzt mit dem Bundestag vergleicht wird eigentlich so einer einzelnen Abgeordneten viel mehr Verantwortung auferlegt also das liegt wahrscheinlich allein schon daran dass es weniger Verwaltungsapparat gibt,
Tag ist das dann vielleicht eher so das neue Vorschläge irgendwie aus dem Ministerium kommt vorbereitet werden und so weiter,
und die einzelnen Abgeordneten zwar irgendwie viel Medienarbeit machen viel Ausschuss Arbeit machen aber vielleicht weniger tatsächlich die politische Linie ihrer Fraktion vorgeben,
und das ist im.
Im Europaparlament wirklich ganz stark also ich habe schon das Gefühl dass wenn ich Berichterstatterin bin oder Schatten Berichterstatterin für irgendein Thema,
dass ich dann mit der Stimme von meinen 51 Abgeordneten in der Fraktion spreche,
und das ist ja einerseits total cool weil man da sehr viel Gestaltungsspielraum hat und wirklich was verändern kann andererseits aber halt auch extrem anstrengend weil,
wenn ich mir denke also es ist so ein running gag das z.b. freie Software bei allen möglichen Gesetzgebungsverfahren einfach komplett vergessen wird also dass es sowas überhaupt gibt dass es freit Lizenzen gibt dass manche Leute irgendwie Dinge,
unter einer freien Lizenz veröffentlichen wollen,
und dass ich dann letzten Endes die Aufgabe habe bei jedem einzelnen Gesetzgebungsverfahren irgendwie die Kommission da dran zu erinnern dass.
Und es irgendwie zu berücksichtigen und dann denkst du mir immer oh Gott wenn ich jetzt,
nicht da wäre oder wenn ich mal eine Woche krank bin dann passieren schlimme Dinge also das ist dann auch irgendwie relativ aufreibend irgendwie,
ja ist denn manchmal so eine so eine Urlaubsort Zeit auch ich bin voller sinnvoller Ausgleich auch wenn ich da nicht leider den Kopf hast verpasst habe dieses Jahr.
Na ja man kann nicht alles haben Thomas.
Ja ich glaube daran.
Kannst du irgendwie auch noch ein anderes Feedback geben dazu so was jetzt eigentlich ist Brüssel so wie du es dir vorgestellt hast ist die ganze i,
EU Arbeit von der von der Intensität der und auch so von den Menschen die du kennengelernt hast da muss es ja auch unheimlich viel Menschen in diesem Parlament gerade weiß dann am Ende doch ganz stark davon abhängt welche Personen verantwortlich sind für die einzelnen Tussis.
Ja total also einerseits bin ich glaube ich irgendwie,
optimistischer geworden über den politischen Betrieb und gleichzeitig auch zynisch also z.b. was für mich eine total positive Erfahrung war,
glaube ich in dieser Form im Bundestag so nicht passieren würde wäre dass ich das Gefühl hatte so in den drei Jahren den ersten drei Jahren im Parlament wo ich ganz viele recht gemacht habe dass ich da,
die damalige Berichterstatterin für die größte,
Sohn die irgendwie aus dem Alltag haben und auch von den Konservativen war mehr oder weniger davon überzeugen konnte dass wir eine progressive UEFA,
und es wird ja auch immer gesagt na ja Politiker die werfen sich ja gegenseitig ihre Argumente an den Kopf aber.
Das wirklich jemand mal seine Meinung ändert so irgend,
Empfang alle ihre Befehle aus ihrer Hauptstadt also das ist hier wirklich nicht so ich habe schon das Gefühl dass es möglich ist,
Position von einzelnen Abgeordneten zu ändern was mich dann gleichzeitig wieder zu nicht gemacht hat ist das ist doch,
zwar nicht und Fraktionszwang aber schon eine starke,
Disziplin eben gerade in diesem großen Fraktionen gibt es ist glaube ich,
gerade für Ihr links progressive Themen großer Nachteil das eigentlich die Linken Fraktion immer viel gespaltener sind als die Rechten Fraktion was einfach daran liegt dass die hierarchischer organisiert sind und im Zweifelsfall halt auch.
Sanktionieren wenn ich jemand gegen die Fraktion hingestellt und ich glaube das wird insbesondere beim Leistungsschutzrecht das jetzt irgendwie auf der Agenda steht noch eine ganz große Herausforderung weil.
Es gibt Leute auch unter den konservativen die ganz klar gesagt haben der alten das Leistungsschutzrecht Schwachsinn die Frage ist bloß ob sie sich dann am Ende trauen werden gegen einen deutschen CDU Berichterstatter auch tatsächlich war sie mit uns abzustimmen.
Ja das ist ja so ewig wiederkehrende Geschichte so diese judäische Volksfront und die Volksfront von Judäa die sich nicht so richtig zusammenraufen kann na ja.
Habe vorwärts auf die einzelnen Themen eingehen vielleicht sollten wir doch mal ganz grob so diesen you Gesetzgebungsprozess Nachzeichnen weil das ist immer noch viel zu wenig Menschen bewusst wie eigentlich Gesetze in Europa gemacht werden.
Ja ich glaube das ist auch zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt besonders wichtig zu wissen weil wie gesagt in eineinhalb Jahren sind Europawahlen,
und im Moment ist gerade eine Phase wo das Europaparlament extrem viel zu tun hat und das liegt eben an diesem Gesetzgebung,
das funktioniert wo das Initiativrecht also das Recht neue Gesetzgebung Vorschläge vorzulegen liegt ausschließlich bei der Europäischen Kommission.
Und weil die Kommission genauso wie das Parlament auf 5 Jahre gewählt ist versuchen die natürlich immer.
Möglichst viele Gesetzgebungsverfahren auch innerhalb ihrer Legislaturperiode abzuschießen das heißt am Anfang.
Nach der Europawahl gibt erstmal ganz viele Vorschläge und gegen Ende werden es immer weniger das heißt das also das Europaparlament und auch der Rat wo die nationalen Regierungen organisiert sind,
die Arbeiten selbst keine neuen Gesetzgebung vorschnelle aus,
aber sie verändern die Vorschläge der Kommission und stimmen über diese ab das heißt letzten Endes kann kein,
keine europäische Richtlinien keine europäische Verordnung ohne die Zustimmung des Europaparlaments verabschiedet werden und wir können Änderungen vornehmen,
aber wir können nur zu den Themen Gesetze verabschieden zu den uns von der Kommission auch was vorgelegt wird,
und jetzt sind wir halt fast am Ende der Legislatur das heißt wir haben einen riesigen Berg an verschiedenen gesetzgebungs vorstellen auf dem Tisch die wir jetzt alle versuchen werden möglichst.
Noch bis 2019 zu beenden was wirklich gar nicht so einfach sein wird.
Am Blech hatten wir das doch gleich mal für dein gesetztes Bereich durchexerzieren also wir haben bei der letzten das letzte Mal als du ballon Netflix zu Gasthaus das war 2015 am Kamp.
Ante da.
Wusste man ja schon das ist ein Vorschlag von der Kommission zum Urheberrecht geben wird aber der war der noch nicht draußen und so ich glaube es gab auch noch keine leaks das heißt das ganze Feld war noch offen und wir haben ja glaube ich auch viele über theoretische Verbesserungen gesprochen die ist eigentlich bräuchte um,
dem aber reicht dann längst notwendiges Update zu geben das ist irgendwie bisschen Internet kompatible wird und vielleicht auch kompatibel bezüglich freier Lizenzen,
geht ja auch er noch nicht angelegt sind im jetzigen recht Bestand am und wenn er zu zurückdenkst und 2015 was ist.
Damals passiert was ist vielleicht noch so mit deinen Erwartungen von damals passiert.
Ja also 2015 da wartete das Europaparlament sehnlichst auf einen Vorschlag zur Rechtsreform also der Wand gleich am Anfang schon im Wahlkampf.
Von Kommissionspräsident Juncker angekündigt werden hier ist es gibt einen großen Urheberrecht,
dann ist ewig nichts passiert und das Parlament hat sich entschlossen diese Zwischenzeit zu nutzen und zumindest einen Initiativbericht,
verabschieden also wo wir,
wann ich als gesetzt aber zumindest eine Willensbekundung darlegen was wir eigentlich im Urheberrecht ändern wollen dafür war ich die Berichterstatterin und habe da auch eine ganze Reihe von erfolgen,
also da hat sich das Europaparlament vor allen Dingen dafür ausgesprochen dass das Urheberrecht,
europäischer wird und verbraucherfreundliche da muss man ja sagen also 2016 als dann der Vorschlag endlich kam,
der war aus der Feder von Günther Oettinger der damals noch für digitale zuständig war eigentlich haben die diesen Bericht des Parlaments fast vollständig ignoriert.
Und letzten Endes auch den den ursprünglichen Auftrag das ursprüngliche Ziel dass er formuliert hatte irgendwie das Recht europäischer machen davon ist da wenig übrig.
Die also es gibt zwar ein paar ganz gezielte versuche ein paar Bereiche,
das Urheberrecht europäische vereinheitlichen die sich.
Im Bereich Bildung und Wissenschaft befinden das ist sicherlich auch wichtig aber dadurch ändert sich halt nichts daran dass im Alltag wenn man irgendwie.
Welchen Jazz benutzt oder oder irgendwelche Remixes macht oder sich sonst in irgendeiner Form,
als Privatperson kreativ mit Kultur im Internet auseinandersetzt,
dass das nach wie vor alles mindestens in eine Grauzone ist also da gibt es überhaupt keine innovativen Vorschläge von der Kommission irgendwie sowas wie eine remix Schranke oder so zu machen.
Ja stattdessen gibt's halt irgendwie den Vorschlag für ein europäisches Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger das übrigens in meinem Bericht damals das Parlament explizit abgelehnt hatte und da ist natürlich klar dass das,
ganze die die Handschrift von Günther Oettinger trägt der einfach mit den.
Deutschen Klosterladen Axel Springer insbesondere immer sehr gute Kontakte hatte und wahrscheinlich am meisten Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat der Vorschlag,
eine Pflicht zum Filtern von urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalten für,
Plattform aller Art etwas glaube ich eine große Katastrophe.
Wieso hat sich,
Hettinger da eigentlich durchgesetzt das aber wenn Junker ich glaube das war auch in seiner Antrittsrede als Kommissionspräsident da hat er sich sehr klar bei dem Thema positioniert und dann ist im Grunde was ganz anderes,
ein Gesetz gestanden obwohl das Parlament sich ja jeder positiv und Vision zur Seite gestellt hat mit der Industrie im Rücken da einfach mehr Gewicht oder,
kannst du von außen irgendwie beurteilen wieso dieser Kommissionsvorschlag so schlecht waren.
Also ich würde glaube ich gar nicht sagen dass ich da Oetinger gegenüber Junker durchgesetzt hat sondern das Junkers eigentlich von Anfang an nicht ernst gemeint hat also,
wenn man sich heutzutage die Statements von Junker anschaut dann sind die stockkonservativ,
das genaue Gegenteil von dem was er am Anfang gesagt hat also z.b. irgendwie letztes Jahr in der Rede zur Lage der Union hat Juncker plötzlich gesagt ja,
die Presseverleger die müssen geschützt werden völlig egal ob ihre Inhalte mit dem,
Kopierer kopiert werden oder im Internet verlinkt werden,
also dass diese Idee dass links kostenpflichtig sein sollen die hat es tatsächlich in die Rede zur Lage der Union von Juncker geschafft insofern also meine Interpretation ist nicht das,
Oettinger Juncker überzeugt hat sondern das Junker uns mehr oder weniger verarscht als am Anfang,
Alligator gesagt hat wir modernisieren das Recht das war eine populäre Forderungen die man im Wahlkampf so stellt und naja nach der Wahl,
erinnert man sich dann nicht mehr dran.
Dönerladen Leistungsschutzrecht oder der Link steuer wieso auch gerne genannt wird das glaube ich.
Ist schon Thema was die meisten Daten was sagen wird Wasser in Deutschland schon gesetzt ist gibt es irgendwelche großen Änderungen zwischen dem Status Quo in Deutschland und dem was jetzt auf EU-Ebene vorgestellt wird.
Das noch mal besser oder schlimmer.
Also ich glaube,
das Leistungsschutzrecht was auf EU-Ebene diskutiert wird ist auf jeden Fall schlimmer in zweierlei Hinsicht also einmal ist das deutsche Leistungsschutzrecht hier nur anwendbar gegen,
News Aggregatoren und Suchmaschinen also das heißt,
eine Privatperson die irgendwie in Deutschland Link setzt die muss ich normalerweise mit dem Leistungsschutz.
Beschäftigen es ist aber schon ein Problem für Startups die halt teilweise auch nach dem deutschen Leistungsschutzrecht verklagt.
Der andere wichtige Unterschied ist.
Das in Deutschland einzelne Wörter oder kleine Textausschnitte von diesem Leistungsschutzrecht ausgenommen sind das heißt also ein.
Rainer nackter Link eine URL die normalerweise nur die Überschrift von dem Presseartikel enthält ist in den meisten Fällen,
nach dem deutschen Leistungsschutzrecht keine Verletzung es sei denn es handelt sich irgendwie um eine besonders lange Überschrift.
Allerdings besteht halt in Deutschland auch nach wie vor totale Rechtsunsicherheit was eigentlich keine Textausschnitt überhaupt sein sollen also das deutsche Leistungsschutz.
Eigentlich kann man.
Vollständig gescheitert betrachten weil diese Rechtsstreitigkeiten über die Details viel viel mehr Geld kosten als Verlage jemals irgendwie Unrecht einnehmen.
Total ist Eigentor das europäische Leistungsschutzrecht soll außerdem auch noch für 2 Jahre nach Veröffentlichung.
Das heißt sie wollen im Grunde genommen Rückweg.
Alle Presseartikel die im Internet ja mehr oder weniger seit Beginn des Internets veröffentlicht wurden mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht zu schützen und das wäre eine totale Katastrophe weil natürlich das gesamte Internet schon voll ist mit Link.
Und wenn dieses Leistungsschutzrecht jetzt rückwirkend eingeführt wird dann geht's natürlich Unmengen an statischen Webseiten wo diese Artikel bereits verlinkt sind die alle plötzlich eine Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Obwohl vielleicht die Person die diese Website erstellt hat die überhaupt nicht mehr pflegt also das wäre wirklich.
Ja eine Einladung für für absurde abmalen wählen die man sich glaube ich garnicht vorstellen kann der Grund weshalb halt das Leistungsschutzrecht als Link steuer bezeichnet wird ist.
Anders als beim Urheberrecht ein Leistungsschutzrecht eben auch unwesentliche Ausschnitte aus einem Artikel also bei Müll berechnet es so natürlich sind Presseartikel urheberrechtlich geschützt.
Aber eine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist es nur dann wenn man einen Teil davon übernimmt der so lang ist dass dieser Abschnitt.
Für sich genommen bereits irgendwie eine intellektuelle Leistung darstellt das heißt die Überschrift von dem Artikel kann man in den meisten Fällen problemlos in einem Link verbreiten.
Aber Naturschutzrecht ist das nicht so und noch dazu gibt es eben auch keinerlei Ausnahmefall cine Wörter oder kleine Ausschnitte also das heißt mit anderen Worten.
Ja wenn ich einen Link setze auf eine auf einen Presseartikel nach diesem Leistungsschutzrecht dann muss ich dafür bezahlen was natürlich auch für die Presse,
total bescheuert ist bei dir darauf angewiesen sind,
das andere Leute auf sie verlegen also gerade kleinere Presseverlage beziehen den Großteil ihrer Leser nicht über direkte Aufruf ihrer Webseite sondern über Links.
Von Social Media von Suchmaschinen oder von privaten webseite,
und insofern ja die einzigen die daran irgendein Interesse haben könnten wären die allergrößten Verlage die dann hoffen dass die Leute vielleicht,
Bild.de gehen wenn keine Links mehr auf Facebook.
Also insofern das ganzes glaube ich absolut kontraproduktiv und ja schlecht damit wieder.
Internet eigentlich funktioniert erstmal von einer Quelle auf eine andere verlegt.
Und wie klein muss so eine Headline sein damit sie eigentlich noch in den Schutzbereich hinein fällt also sowas wie Merkel trifft Trump.
Kennt ihr das noch von einem Leistungsschutzrecht betroffen sein oder nur wenn es auch verlinkt zu einem Artikel der dass es Hitler in hat.
Also ob es verlinkt oder nicht ist völlig egal die Urheberrechtsverletzung besteht wenn man diesen Inhalt entweder kopiert oder weiterverbreitet insofern,
also ob man auf die Quelle verweist ist unerheblich was die Länge angeht das ist eine gute Frage weil bisher.
Gibt es so ein Leistungsschutzrecht für text überhaupt nicht also das ist eine neue Erfindung die ist auch vor dem deutschen Leistungsschutzrecht in der Form nicht gegeben hat und das deutsche Leistungsschutzrecht hat ja Ex,
diese Ausnahme drin deshalb das einzige was man sich anschauen kann sind andere Leistungsschutzrecht und wie das da geregelt.
Und da gibt's z.b. das Urteil zu Metall auf Metall also das war dieser Rechtsstreit zwischen Kraftwerk und Moses Pelham wo er irgendwie ich glaube drei Sekunden von Metall auf Metall gestempelt hat und da hat.
Letzten Endes das Gericht entschieden dass das Leistungsschutzrecht für Musikaufnahmen Greif.
Das heißt also sehr sehr sehr kurze Ausschnitte aus einer Musikaufnahme sind Leistungsschutzrecht ich geschützt und die Argumentation ist da wird ja nicht irgendwie eine kulturelle Leistung geschützt sondern eine Investition und deshalb ist es egal wie kurz.
Und insofern kann man sich vorstellen dass das dann mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht genauso ist also das ist nicht darauf ankommt.
Kann man natürlich dann völlig ad absurdum treiben also wenn Merkel trifft Trump Leistungsschutzrecht Geschütz.
Dann privatisiert man damit ja quasi die Sprache und also.
Das ist überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar und wahrscheinlich wird es auch verschiedene Pizzen geben die die gleiche Formulierung unabhängig voneinander verwendet haben und dann von verschiedenen Verlagen pro.
Und dann ist völlig unklar ja wer hält jetzt eigentlich das Leistungsschutzrecht an dieser Formulierung also ist völlig absurd und.
Ja widersprichst glaube ich alle wozu das Urheberrecht ursprünglich mal gut sein sollte also,
die meisten also so die Grundregeln des Urheberrechts sind noch in einem Vertrag aus dem 19 Jahrhundert geregelt auf internationaler Ebene in der Berner Übereinkunft.
Und da steht explizit drin.
Das Nachrichten und Tagesgeschehen nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt sein sollen weil das ja auch völlig der Idee von Nachrichten widerspricht dass sich.
Informationen verbreiten können das wird durch das Leistungsschutzrecht einfach komplett außen vor.
Sie noch ein anderes im Recht hatte ich das Problem also wenn du sagst das kannst du von der 20-Jährige Dreißigjährigen Zeitraum Schutz Zeitraum haben.
Und wir haben ganz viele solche Leistungsschutzrecht Verletzungen derzeit im Netz.
Welches rückwirkend treffen soll dann ist doch eigentlich etwas dass ich vor Beschluss eines Gesetzes gemacht habe dann auf einmal illegal und das kann es doch eigentlich nicht geben.
Noch immer nur nach vorne hingesetzt Dinge verbieten und wenn ich mich dann nicht an Gesetze halten kann ich vielleicht irgendwie Schaden haben.
Ja so das ist grundsätzlich richtig und wenn die Handlung die du vorgenommen hast abgeschlossen ist dann bist du davon auch nicht betroffen also wenn du z.b. im Jahr 2000 einen Artikel kopiert hast.
Dann wäre das keine Leistungsschutzrecht Verletzung wenn das Leistungsschutzrecht einge.
Die rückwirkende Geltung ist insofern relevant wenn eine Website noch online ist also wenn du im Jahr 2000 eine Website online gestellt hast und die weiterhin online.
Dann wird gesagt na ja diese Weaver rechts Förderleistung Schutzrechtsverletzung ist nicht abgeschlossen.
Sondern sie besteht weiter fort weil der Inhalt ja immer noch abrufbar ist und solange jemand auf.
In Cannes wird quasi die Leistungsschutzrecht Verletzung mich in der Vergangenheit im Jahr 2000 verortet sondern heute.
Und das ist also das,
Durst in gewisser Weise das rechtsstaatliche Problem hilft aber den Leuten die davon betroffen sind überhaupt nicht weiter aber man kann ja nicht sagen ihr müsst ihr jetzt um Rechtssicherheit bewahren alle Webseiten offline neben dir nicht mehr irgendwie kontrolliert.
Ja wahnsinn ich meinte dass man nahezu gewertet das würde man eine Aussage tätigen so wie beim das nicht.
Beispiel Wiederbetätigungsgesetz ja du kannst irgendwie ein Blödsinn sagen der Feuermann okay was du sagst ihn wieder na jetzt haben wir aber angesetzt was das Regiment irrt an damit bist du außen vor an eine Webseite nicht aktualisiert,
wurde aber weiterhin dem letztes Ziel sozusagen wie eine neue Äußerung das ist wahrscheinlich die Logik.
Ja und wenn man sich das überlegt also z.b. was ist für die Wikipedia bedeuten würde die müssen eigentlich alle bestehenden Artikel,
teilweise schon vor Jahren geschrieben wurden und möglicherweise aktualisiert vor und zwischendurch durchforsten nach links,
Presseartikel und die dann entsprechend entfernen oder anpassen also völlig völlig an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
An in den meisten also wir haben ja ein paar EU Länder wo es und Leistungsschutzrecht schon gibt Deutschland Spanien und Belgien und da.
Ja in Belgien nicht so dann wurde es vorgeschlagen aber da hat man dann letzten Endes doch festgestellt dass es eine schlechte Idee ist und hat sich irgendwie anderweitig geeinigt.
Juhu aber in Spanien und Deutschland was doch immer so das Leistungsschutzrecht ist ja ein bisschen so ein Lex Google und man versucht irgendwie Google News dazu Kasse zu bitten was aber in keinem dieser Länder hier funktioniert hat sondern.
Google hat dann eben mit seiner Marktmacht meistens Ausnahme bekommen,
als ich von solchen design steel verwehrt bzw da wo man einspannen glaube ich war es versucht hat Google dazu zwingen solche Lizenzvereinbarungen einzugehen habe sie einfach Google News abgeschalten gibt's.
Irgendein Grund zu glauben dass das jetzt auf europäischer Ebene anders wäre dass man da ist schafft irgendwie Google unserem Deal zu zwingen.
Ja also eigentlich nicht ich glaube das stärkste Emotion alle Argument für das Leistungsschutzrecht dass ich auch immer wieder von Kolleginnen und Kollegen höre ist.
Na ja die Verlage haben finanzielle Einbußen sie hatten früher große Einnahmen aus Werbung die sind alle weg gebrochen.
Und heute verdient Google dieses Geld mit der Werbung was ja auch richtig ist also das heißt ja die das Aufkommen von Google Adwords,
und die Dominanz von Google im Werbemarkt hat tatsächlich den Zeitung geschadet.
Der Fehler in der Logik des Leistungsschutzrecht ist zu glauben dass hätte irgendwas mit dem Urheberrecht,
weil der Grund weshalb Google so viel Geld mit Werbung verdienen ist ja nicht dass sie kostenlos auf Presseartikel fanden können sondern dass sie im großen Stil persönliche Daten sammeln und dadurch gezielt personalisierte Werbung aus,
das heißt.
Eigentlich meiner Meinung nach wenn man dieses Problem angehen will der Dominanz von Google auf dem Werbemarkt dann muss man einerseits die Datenschutzgesetze verschärfen um sicherzustellen dass Google halt mit,
also nicht.
Unbegrenzt personalisierte Werbung und andererseits möglicherweise den Werbemarkt selbst regulieren also da gibt's ja auch viele,
Diskussion darüber inzwischen ob alles das was an Google und Facebook Werbung.
Praktiziert wird auch teilweise im Wahlkampf ob das alles so legal sein sollte und es ist eigentlich nur Diskussionen die es sich lohnt zu haben nur das hat alles mit dem Urheberrecht nichts zu tun und das Leistungsschutzrecht geht davon aus,
das Google Geld verdient weil es auf die Verlage verlinken darf,
und dass die Verlage darunter leiden das Google auf die verlinkt weil dann ja Leute bereits die hätten 1 die Nachrichten direkt auf Google lesen können oder direkt auf Facebook und gar nicht mehr auf die Artikel klicken.
Und das ist empirisch einfach falsch also ist es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Studien die so das Nutzerverhalten an evaluieren und insgesamt ist das Ergebnis dass,
die Verlage davon profitieren wenn auf sie verlegt wird also auch wenn ein Snippet angezeigt wird wo man die ersten zwei Sätze lesen kann und zwar,
je kleiner der Verlag ist ihr spezialisierter der Verlag ist desto wichtiger ist es zu werden also Bild.de.
Da gehen vielleicht noch die Mehrheit der Leute direkt auf die Webseite aber heiße z.b. oder eine Regionalzeitung bekommt die Mehrheit ihrer,
Leserinnen und Leser in Berlin und das ist ja auch total logisch also die.
Die ganz großen Massen Zeitung da gehen die Leute vielleicht routiniert jeden Tag drauf um sich irgendwie übers Tagesgeschehen zu informieren aber die spezialisierten Artikel die werden dann gelesen wenn irgendwas passiert,
also wenn es z.b. eine neue Sicherheitslücke gibt dann gehen plötzlich ganz viele Leute auf dem Reiseartikel um sich zu informieren die niemals von sich aus irgendwie auf heise.de gegangen werden,
und also ich glaube das.
Ja letzten Endes mit dem europäischen Datenschutzrecht genau das gleiche passieren wird wie in Deutschland das Leistungsschutzrecht wird eingeführt,
google sagt ja bezahlen dafür nicht dann trinken wir halt nicht auf euch Facebook wahrscheinlich genauso.
Und das Ergebnis ist dass die Verlage sehen plötzlich kommt viel weniger Leute auf Ihre Webseiten sie haben weniger Werbeeinnahmen als vorher und geben dann den großen,
Playern also Google und Facebook eine freie Lizenz damit sie wieder angezeigt werden aber den kleinen Player nicht weil die wirtschaftlich nicht ins Gesicht fallen,
das bedeutet ein Recht das ursprünglich dazu diente irgendwie Geld von Google abzuzocken und den Fall anzugeben führt einfach nur dazu dass die Dominanz dieser großen Plattform noch gesperrt.
Das ist ja auch nicht immer du hast jetzt Wikipedia angesprochen und im Grunde gibt's ja dann noch viel mehr Stakeholder die unter die Kollateralschäden von so einem Leistungsschutzrecht fallen.
Am gleichzeitig haben.
Nachrichten Verlag ich hier ein großes Eigeninteresse in diesem Thema wie wirkt sich das denn auf die politische Debatte aus ist ja an sich schon so dass es sehr schwierig ist zu EU Themen.
Gute Berichterstattung zu bekommen vor allem bevor die Abstimmungen passieren und.
Gleichzeitig gibt's ja jetzt seit einigen Jahren auch politico Europe an die Handy ja auch Springer gewisse Anteile hält,
wie ist das denn für dich als jemand der eine klare Position hat und wie beobachtest du das bei deinem Kollegen wie wie beeinflusst das die politische Debatte.
Ja also bei politico fällt es schon auf dass die eigentlich überhaupt nicht kritisch über das Datenschutzrecht berichten also da.
Ist es schon relativ ja offensichtlich,
dass die dem ganzen grundsätzlich eher positiv gegenüberstehen ich glaube nicht dass das bei allen.
Zeitungen so ist die Form Verlag rausgegeben werden,
der für das Ei zum Schutz Recht ist also ich glaube in manchen Redaktion voll sein ist die,
Trennung zwischen wirtschaftlicher und redaktioneller Seite ordentlich bei politiko habe ich eher das Gefühl dass das doch teilweise miteinander vermengt ist.
Deckt sich mit meiner Erfahrung aus dem netto alles jetzt Bereich das war auch so das da.
Ja ehemalige Kommissions Mitarbeiter auf einmal in home Position bei Politik Uwe an,
die haben einfach dieselbe Position die sie früher bei der Kommission gegen Netzneutralität vertreten haben eins zu eins in die redaktionelle Linie von Politikern mitgenommen was sehr schade ist weil an sich bräuchte gutes Medium was,
Politik mal in der aufbereitet für die Leute die den ganzen Folgen wollen.
Ja also ich will auch nicht sagen das irgendwie politiko an sich,
schlecht wäre also ich glaube die Idee so ein Medium zu haben das machen wirksam über EU-Politik Bericht erstattet ist absolut wichtig aber ja das ist dann natürlich besonders frustrierend wenn man dann das Gefühl hat.
Dass da eine Seite der Debatte viel weniger zu Wort und ich finde es auch in dem Kontext ganz interessant zu erwähnen die,
der Rechtsausschuss im Europaparlament der zuständig ist für die Urheberrechtsreform hat eine Studie in Auftrag gegeben,
woran Wissenschaftler versucht haben rauszufinden wie populär das Leistungsschutzrecht ist bei den Redaktionen und bei den Verlagen die davon unmittelbar betroffen sind also das heißt sie haben.
Redaktion und Verlage in Deutschland und in Spanien befragt sich Experteninterviews,
und die Ergebnisse waren wirklich vernichtend also im Grunde genommen alle die bereit waren mit ihm zu sprechen.
Wann sehr kritisch gegenüber dem Leistungsschutzrecht haben gesagt hat ihn eigentlich nicht gebracht,
teilweise sogar die Verlage die früher für das Datenschutzrecht blockiert haben haben gesagt also das hat sich als Fehler herausgestellt besonders interessant war aber auch in der Studie dass mehrere Redaktion,
gesagt haben wir möchten Diba nicht an der Studie teilnehmen weil wir mit der Linie unseres Verlages nicht einverstanden,
ich dann eben nicht in eine Position begeben wollten also wo die Redaktion das eine sagt und der Verlag das andere das finde ich ja sehr ehrlich und auch in Ordnung wenn man das so handhabt über.
Das deutet halt schon darauf hin dass es wahrscheinlich da auch innerhalb von manchen Situationen Konflikte.
Habe ich letztens du wunderschöne Verschwörungstheorie gehört,
wenn jetzt immer mehr schon dann ist es ja inhalt algorithmisch erstellt wird das ist eigentlich keine Arthur mehr von diesen Artikel gibt dann habe ich ja im Grunde auch kein Urheberrecht,
mehr an diesen eigentlichen Inhalt.
Aber über das Leistungsschutzrecht können sich die Presseverleger dann immer noch ein Schutzrecht zumindest für die Titel von diesen Algorithmus generiert Texten besorgen.
Ja absolut richtig also nicht nur die Titel also das ist genau korrekt.
Artikel die von einem Algorithmus geschrieben wurden sind nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt aber sie sind Leistungsschutzrecht,
also das ist absolut klar was ist Leistungsschutzrecht keine Schöpfungshöhe Vorsicht also da kommt es nicht darauf an dass sie man kreativ war,
also absolut richtig ich glaube das ist noch nicht meine Verschwörungstheorie das wird auch teilweise wirklich so argumentativ eingebracht also zuletzt,
von den Presseagenturen das war ganz interessant die haben nämlich einen also in der französischen Zeitung le mont,
ein großen Appell an die EU-Politik gerichtet doch bitte das Leistungsschutzrecht nicht nur anzunehmen sondern auszuweiten und explizit reinzuschreiben dass die Presseagenturen davon auch profitieren können,
und bei der Erklärung lief es daraufhin aus dass die wollen das quasi Leute die die Inhalte aus ihren,
also nicht den Text sondern die Pack.
Aus ihren Agenturmeldungen übernehmen dafür im Seife 2 auch bezahlen ist also das ist relativ.
Logisch dass das Urheberrecht auch nicht greift also wenn ich eine Pressemeldung bekomme.
Und darüber erfahren dass irgendwas passiert ist und dann meinen eigenen Artikel schreibe.
Das Tasca nueva Rechtsverletzung ist aber die Presseagenturen wollen explizit quasi über dieses Leistungsschutzrecht eine Art Schutz aufback.
Und ich fand diesen,
diesen Artikel extrem ja entlarvende irgendwie war genau das was die Verlage uns die ganze Zeit versuchen weiszumachen nein niemand hat vor Fakten zu schützen und darauf kommt es überhaupt nicht an und so dass letzten Endes durch diesen,
Artikel der Presseagentur angezeigt wurde doch genau darum geht es.
Also sozusagen Sofa Fakten Faktura was da irgendwie betrieben wird.
Ja also auch ganz lustig es gab es vor kurzem so ein Rechtsstreit in Deutschland zwischen Springer und Bruder der irgendwie eingestellt wurde weil ich glaube Fokus genau das gemacht hat also die haben sich,
geplante Inhalte von Bild.de oder so durchgelesen.
Exklusiv Nachrichten und dann ihre eigenen Artikel drüber geschrieben was ja auch völlig in Ordnung ist aber dann hat Springer irgendwie verklagt mit der Argumentation dass das irgendwie ja nicht geht also dass man,
exklusive Informationen,
weiterverwendet ohne eine Paywall und wir haben jetzt vor kurzem das Verfahren eingestellt das wundert mich überhaupt nicht wahrscheinlich ist Ihnen aufgefallen dass dieses Verfahren für die Leistungsschutzrecht Debatte,
absolutes Gift ist weil das sind zwei Verlage die beide für das Leistungsschutzrecht sind die sich jetzt vor Gericht darüber streiten ob man Fakten,
wiederholen darf ohne Lizenz oder nicht in sie wahrscheinlich selber gemerkt dass ist nicht so schlau ist und haben sich dann außergerichtlich geeinigt.
Also ich glaube wir müssen marc-Uwe Kling bescheid sagen der hat er in seiner Dystopie noch was vergessen.
Ja wirklich.
Das ja.
An bevor wir zum nächsten schönen Thema kommen es gab da ja auch noch so eine Studie der EU-Kommission zu diesem Thema die du über über lustige Wege dann der Öffentlichkeit zugeführt hast.
Lass mal die Geschichte.
Das ist inzwischen schon eine Art Running Gag weil das ist nicht die erste Commission's Studie die ich irgendwie aus einem stillen Kämmerlein befreit habe,
also angefangen hat es damit dass im September glaube ich ich eine Studie veröffentlicht habe wo die Kommission festgestellt hatte dass es keinerlei Hinweise darauf,
dass die Verfügbarkeit oder der Konsum von illegalen.
Inhalten im Netz also Urheberrechtsverletzungen Inhalten zu Einbrüchen in den Verkaufszahlen von legalen Inhalten führt also mit der Ausnahme von.
Blockbustern also die gerade erst ins Kino gekommen sind wo sie so ein Effekt feststellen konnten bei den anderen untersuchten.
Medien konnten sie überhaupt keinen Effekt feststellen sogar bei Computerspielen war es andersrum also dass Leute die illegale Computerspiele konsumiert haben sogar.
Häufiger im Anschluss Spiele gekauft haben was ich auch nicht so besonders überraschend finden.
Das hatte ich veröffentlicht nachdem ich eine Informationsfreiheit Anfrage gestellt hatte also.
Kann so ich hatte halt irgendwie festgestellt dass die Kommission eine Ausschreibung für so eine Studie gemacht hatte schon Jahre vorher aber komischerweise war die Studie nirgendwo.
Also dachte ich mir das kann ja nicht sein die Ausschreibung ist schon Jahre her die haben dafür irgendwie tausende Steuergelder ausgegeben damit muss ja irgendwas.
Also halte dich diese Informationsfreiheit Anfrage gestellt und habe die Studie dann bekommen.
Ja das war insofern relativ bekannt dass die halt schon über ein Jahr fertig in einer Schublade lag und einfach wie hat der Öffentlichkeit vorenthalten.
In dem jetzigen Fall ist es noch ein bisschen brisanter weiß dann genau um einen.
Ja konkreten Vorschlag der EU-Kommission geht also irgendwie Einführung eines solchen Atemschutz.
Also nachdem ich diese Studie zu den illegalen Inhalten bekommen hatte dachte ich mir na ja.
Da gibt's ja bestimmt noch mehr also habe ich eine Informationsfreiheit Anfrage gestellt an die Kommission dass Sie mir bitte alle Studien die bisher unveröffentlicht sind zum Urheberrecht aus den letzten vier Jahren.
Und einen Tag bevor die Frist für die Informationsfreiheit Anfrage.
Ausgelaufen ist hat die Kommission heimlich still und leise ich glaube vier verschiedene Urheberrecht Studien veröffentlicht weil ja dann waren sie ja nichtmal unveröffentlicht und dann mussten sie mir nicht mehr schicken ich habe es natürlich trotzdem gesehen aber es war nicht so ganz.
Zusätzlich kam dann aber eben auch noch eine Antwort vom Joint Research Centre also das ist quasi ein Teil der Europäischen Kommission der einerseits der Kommission untergeben ist andererseits aber genau die Funktion hat.
Unabhängige wissenschaftliche Studien für die Kommission.
Und also ich hatte mit denen in der Vergangenheit auch schon zu tun weil z.b. das Joint Research Center auch in der dieselgate Affäre eine Rolle gespielt hat also die haben.
Relativ früh schon festgestellt dass irgendwie bei den Dieselautos gepfuscht wurde.
Und auch dort gab es halt die Anzeichen dafür dass möglicherweise die Kommission diese Informationen ja nicht weiter verfolgt hat nicht veröffentlicht.
Die haben mir eben auch eine Studie geschickt zum Leistungsschutzrecht und die hatte es echt in sich also diese Studie kommt zum Schluss dass das Leistungsschutzrecht in jeder Hinsicht kontraprodukt.
Verlage insbesondere kleine Verlage davon profitieren wenn sie verlinkt werden und dass man zwar ein Leistungsschutzrecht einführen kann aber dass dieses Leistungsschutzrecht auf dem Markt immer einen Wert von 0 hat.
Weil letztenendes der Wert des verlinkt werden mindestens genauso hoch ist wie der Wert des verlinkten insofern gibt es keinen Anreiz oder keine Nachfrage für so ein Eis.
Und insofern also ja wird die Erwartung bestätigt dass Google und Facebook am Ende eine freilich.
Diese Studie ja habe ich dann auch veröffentlicht und darüber geschrieben.
Und die Kommission hat ein bisschen also hat sich vor allen Dingen dadurch in die Nesseln gesetzt.
In dieser Information Preisanfrage nicht nur die Studie enthalten war sondern auch eine E-Mail die explizit des Joint Research Centre dazu auffordert die Studie nicht so veröffentlich.
Und also das hatten wir bisher nicht das ist quasi schwarz auf weiß zu sehen ist das die Kommission die Veröffentlichung dieser Studie verhindert.
Also von wem denkst du den geht denn so zeigen diese Initiative aus das nicht zu veröffentlichen also wer übt da auf wen in welchem Maße Druck aus damit sowas nicht passiert oder das tut weh was zur Unterdrückung stattfindet.
Also genau in Ministerien gibt es in der Kommission eine politische Ebene und eine administrative EU.
Die Leute in Joint Research Center das sind ja gelernte Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler die einfach versuchen ihren Job.
Den wird eine Forschungsfrage gestellt und die Arbeiten dann in der Regel denke ich ordentlich und versuchen diese Forschungsfrage zu beantworten.
Die Kommission hingegen ist oder zumindest die Führungsebene der Kommission die Kommissare selber und deren cabinetul sind keine Verwaltung sondern politische Organe.
Also das heißt dort wird so eine Art von edry hat das als policy based evidence.
Also mit anderen Worten die Kommission versucht ihre politischen Entscheidungen so darzustellen als wären sie wissenschaftlich begründet.
Aber wenn die wissenschaftlichen Studien diesen Auftrag geben nicht dazu passen dann ja werden sie halt unterschlagen also das heißt im Grunde genommen.
Werden so viele Studien in Auftrag gegeben bis vielleicht einer dabei ist die in die Argumentation passt und die wird dann als Untermauerung wissenschaftliche Untermauerung der politischen Entscheidungen.
Und ich glaube also das ist einfach extrem unehrlich ich bin gar nicht der Meinung dass jedes politisch Unterfangen wissenschaftlich begründet sein muss man kann auch.
Wir treffen hier eine Werte Entscheidung dass wir das eine oder das andere vorschlagen wollen völlig unabhängig davon ob das jetzt in tierisch mauert ist aber dann muss man so ehrlich sein und das aufzugeben und beim Leistungsschutzrecht ist es halt klar.
Die gesamte Wissenschaft der Meinung ist dass dieses Datenschutzrecht unwirksam ist und das was uns hier versprochen wird als.
Nämlich dass Google und Facebook einen Teil ihrer Gewinne an die Verlage abgeben werden einfach durch dieses Instrument nicht erreicht wird und gleichzeitig es halt eine Reihe von wegen Nebenwirkung.
Nebenwirkungen ist schon untertrieben also das ist wirklich ne.
Enorme Gefahr für für Informationsfreiheit und Film. Auch die Entwicklung unserer Gesellschaft und sonst vorstellen.
Was was um Kontrolle Regime für Konsequenzen hätte und das.
Es ist eine Form auf von zentralisierter Kontrolle die im Grunde dann ja auch hier dicker deine Taschen sind umso stärker ausgeübt werden kann die.
Aufbau vielleicht mit demokratischen Gesellschaften gar nicht mehr.
Vereinbar wäre gut man kann sich da auch irgendwie in den freien Lizenz Bereich retten aber wahrscheinlich wäre es dann so dass man auch in vielen Ländern um journalistische Grundrechte umfallen würde und dann halt eben kein Quellenschutz mehr hätte.
Ante.
Ja es ist so schwer mal eine schlechte Idee das muss ich eigentlich gar nicht verstehen kann wieso das irgendjemand für sinnvoll halten kann.
Also.
Ja ich glaube das auch ein ganz wichtiges Korrektiv und wie wechselt bei dieser Richtlinie weil in Deutschland ist es ja so.
Nach nachdem das iPhone Schutzrecht eingeführt wurde mussten schon irgendwie viele anerkennen dass es im Nachhinein nicht funktioniert hat also z.b.
die FDP die ja damals mit einer Region war die sagt inzwischen auch eher so also Leutheusser-Schnarrenberger die damalige Ministerin sagt das war eigentlich.
Und wir sollten das jetzt nicht weiter treiben und im letzten Koalitionsvertrag stand auch drin das Leistungsschutzrecht so irgendwie noch mal evaluiert.
In dem Moment wo das jetzt auf EU-Ebene eingeführt wird verhindert man glaube ich das.
Ja dass man letztenendes einen Fehler wieder rückgängig machen weil diese Richtlinie schreib.
Boah das alle mit gestanden das Datenschutzrecht ein.
Und das danach wieder abzuschaffen ist extrem schwierig weil kein Mitgliedstaat kann sagen okay wir sehen jetzt in der Praxis die Folgen sind fatal wir schaffen es wieder abweisend sind ja durch die Richtlinien gebunden.
Selbst wenn man die richtige abschafft hilft das erstmal nicht weil das ja nicht automatisch die nationalen Gesetze ändert also ist wie mit wie mit der Vorrat.
Du hast Datenspeicherung genommen werden.
Also die die Richtlinie wurde als Grund rechtswidrig abgeschafft aber die nationalen Gesetze sind erstmal bestehen geblieben und die Gefahr besteht hier natürlich auch.
Na davon ab also ich glaube das Leistungsschutzrecht hat fatale Folgen aber diese Studie was das letzten Endes auch Zeit,
wie die Kommission eigentlich arbeitet und ich finde das relativ erschreckend bei,
Everest ist jetzt ein Thema mit dem ich mich intensiv auseinandersetzte aber ich frage mich halt wie viele andere Themen gibt es eigentlich noch.
Wo die Kommission gezielt Studien zurückhält die ihren politischen Ziele widersprechen,
und das sind ja alle Studien die irgendwann Steuergerät werden und die dazu dienen sollen unsere unsere politischen Entscheidungen besser zu untermauern und zu überprüfen.
Was für anderen Themen ist noch geben kann das ist eine schöne Überleitung zu dem Thema Abluftfilter was ich persönlich für eine noch größere Schweinerei halte und,
eine noch größere Gefahr fürs frei Internet am.
Das ist der berühmte Artikel 13 in der Oettinger urheberrechtsrichtlinie zudem.
Wir wir hier glaube ich auch in der Sendung schon abseits deiner besuche ich halt mal was dazu gesagt weil ich das wirklich so für die größte Gefahr auf europäischer Ebene im Moment halte und.
Ja vielleicht kannst du uns ja auch mal Gruppen Abriss geben kannst das noch mal besser machen was ich die letzten Male.
Ja also ich glaube bei dem Thema ist die Lage auch wirklich dramatisch weil das,
er kann einen Einfluss darauf haben wie also im schlimmsten Fall dass,
das Internet wieder von so einer viele zu viele Kommunikation,
rasant auf eine wenige zu viele Kommunikation zusteuert also dass das Internet wieder mehr so wird für das Kabelfernsehen es ist ohnehin schon interessant,
das für viele Leute irgendwie das Internet nur noch Facebook ist und das glaube ich auch ja.
Unabhängig von diesen ablauffilter problematisch aber durch diese Upload Filter,
Vorschrift für diese Entwicklung diese Zentralisierung des Internet glaube ich massiv beschleunigen,
denn also die Problemlage ist folgende die Kommission hat sich von der Musikindustrie erklären lassen dass es ein Problem gibt mit YouTube.
Und da kann man sich drüber streiten auch ob dieses Problem nicht tatsächlich existiert nämlich.
Die Klage der Musikindustrie die Leute Laden im großen Stil Musik,
bei YouTube hoch die von den großen Plattenlabels ist und YouTube löscht die nicht sondern stattdessen benutzt YouTube seinen eigenen Filter Content-ID,
um diese Inhalte zu finden,
und bietet den Rechteinhabern an so ja wir könnten sie ja löschen wie das Unsere gesetzliche Vorschrift wäre weil alle Hosting-Provider sind dazu verpflichtet auf Anfrage.
Ein Uwe Rechtsverletzungen Inhalte löschen aber google sagt wir machen euch ein wenig abnehmen könnten wir lassen den Inhalt online und geben euch dafür einen prozentualen Anteil unserer Werbeeinnahmen durch dieses Video,
in der Musikbranche ist es so dass die ganz überwiegende Mehrheit der Rechteinhaber das macht,
weil na ja ein bisschen Geld ist besser als überhaupt kein Geld aber dadurch die Lizenzen mit denen sie.
Normalerweise eben Musik-Streaming verkaufen ihrer.
Argumentation nach entwerten also das Geld was Google zahlt dieser prozentuale Anteil der.
Der Werbeeinnahmen ist einfach viel niedriger als das was sie bekommen würden von einem bezahlen Streamingdienst und.
Das heißt also wenn man das wenn man dieses Argument kauft der Musikindustrie da muss man eigentlich zu dem Schluss kommen das Problem wurde erzeugt durch einen Upload finde nämlich durch Content-ID wenn Google einfach wie es gesetzlich,
sollte die Inhalte löschen würde auf Anfrage dann würde dieses Problem überhaupt nicht bestehen das quasi die Preise von Streaming Diensten unterboten wird.
Und die Antwort der Kommission darauf ist,
das in Zukunft alle Plattformen Upload Filter einsetzen müssen also das im Prinzip alle viel mehr zu werden müssen die YouTube mit deiner Content-ID und das ist für mich einfach ja mein boggling also totaler Unsinn,
letzten Endes aber selbst wenn man,
anerkennt dass dieses Problem existiert letztenendes der Lösungsvorschlag das ganze noch schlimmer macht und sag diese ablauffilter die eigentlich den Konflikt zwischen der Musikindustrie und YouTube überhaupt erzeugt haben die werden jetzt,
zur Lösung all unserer Probleme auserkoren und ich glaube der Grund weshalb die Kommission das Nacht ist letztenendes weil.
Wie ohnehin ein Interesse Upload Filter hat also sie wollen seit langer Zeit glaube ich schon Filter verpflichtungen für alle anderen,
alle möglichen anderen illegalen Inhalte einführen also gegen Terrorismus gegen fake-news was heißt ich nicht,
und die das Urheberrecht ist mal wieder die die Speerspitze in gewisser Weise also wenn Sie das fürs Urheberrecht durchsetzen.
Und die ganzen grundrechtlichen Argumente,
quasi vom Tisch wischen können weil natürlich die die Künstler die hier vor geschickt werden,
irgendwie viel Sympathie genießen dann wird danach wesentlich einfacher sein für die Kommission auch Upload Filter für Terrorismus und andere Themen 1,
und es aber einfach sagen also dieses Filter funktionieren nicht zu löschen im großen Stil,
legale Inhalte ich habe mal ein paar Beispiele davon gesammelt auf meiner Webseite wie heute schon die freiwillig eingesetzten Filter von YouTube und Co,
legale Inhalte löschen und gerade für kleinere Künstler teilweise große Probleme erzeugen und diese Probleme würden sich potenzieren also.
Die kontroversen Diskussionen die wir über das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz in Deutschland haben diese nichts im Vergleich zu einer automatischen löschpflicht wo überhaupt kein Mensch an keinem Zeitpunkt,
des Verfahrens noch mal auf die Inhalte drauf guckt bevor sie gelöscht werden.
Ja das ist definitiv auch so ein Trendthema near City wir wären wir lange über die.
Privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung gesprochen und was ist die Automatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung also da gibt es wirklich nur noch eine Filtertechnologie und die ist eine Blackbox die entscheidet ist das jetzt dann urheberrechtlich geschützter.
Inhalt oder nicht,
target hat einfach auch ganz viele legale Nutzungsformen soll ein irgendwas dass ich im Bildungskontext verwende oder als Zitatrecht oder Sparrow die die von Filter niemals erkannt werden können weil der den Kontext nicht kennt an,
am deutlichsten wird das Ganze ich Mama kann irgendwie zurück schauen wir haben in den letzten Jahren eine Anti Terrorismus Richtlinie auf EU-Ebene,
die ist schon beschlossen das war inmitten der Terroranschläge in Europa nicht mal dort war der politische Kompromiss macht bei Abluftfilter reinzubekommen sie haben's Profil.
Interessen haben sie es nicht geschafft jetzt im Urheberrecht stehen wir kurz davor Antike farsi serial dass das kommt und.
Ist ja auch klar wenn das dann Urheberrecht erstmal geschafft wurde dann kann ich umso natürlich einen neuen Vorschlag von Terrorismus vorlegen und sagen hier dann Urheberrecht haben wir's ja schon gemacht und Terrorismus ist ja sicherlich viel schlimmer.
Genau sobald die Technologie da ist und auch in Aalen,
Webseiten integriert ist ist es ja nur noch ein neues Profil hochladen auf die jeweiligen Filter am deutlichsten wird das Ganze wenn man der Wikipedia zuhörte sollte Wikipedia den Verein hinter die sagen wir sind bis jetzt erst von zwei Ländern gefragt worden solche von einem Land bis jetzt erst gefragt worden so ein Filter einzurichten,
und das Vagina und wir haben uns damals geweigert und.
Deswegen sind wir heute in China blockiert und jetzt kommt sowas von höher Europäischen Union also das ist schon der hat der Kontext von dem wir hier sprechen.
Was macht denn bitte was macht denn die Europäische Union wer sich Wikipedia auch in der EU weigert Abluftfilter einzurichten wenn die dann auch gesperrt.
Ja das ist eine gute Frage also weil letztenendes ich glaube alle Politiker in ihrem Arbeitsalltag auf die Wikipedia angewiesen sind erstmal nichts vor ich glaube,
ja wenn das tatsächlich soweit kommen würde dann werden sich einige Leute die Augen reiben und wenn man die Kommission fragt.
Möchtet ihr das Wikipedia von diesem Artikel betroffen ist oder nicht dann sagen die nein nein darum geht's uns überhaupt nicht es geht uns um Google und Facebook nur die Art und Weise wie sie versuchen.
Zu unterscheiden ist völlig ja untauglich also z.b. sagen sie,
ja der Artikel 13 gilt ja nur für platform auf den große Mengen von Inhalten hochgeladen werden,
aber ich glaube es fehlt völlig das Verständnis dafür dass es unglaublich viele Nischen Plattform mit großen Mengen von Inhalten gibt die trotzdem nicht wirtschaftlich besonders,
also z.b. GitHub GitHub ist.
Mit Sicherheit eine Plattform wo große Mengen von Inhalten hochgeladen werden nämlich Software Code und natürlich ist auch per Code auch erstmal urheberrechtlich geschützt,
trotzdem ist es mir nicht bekannt dass es auch geht irgendwie ein großes Problem oder große klagen von Rechteinhabern gelbe dass dort im großen Stil Bericht,
also das ist so so der klassische frei.
Das einfach ja glaube ich der Kommission teilweise das Verständnis dafür fehlt was für Plattform ist eigentlich alles gibt und dass nicht alle urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalte Musikvideos.
Notfallpass was heißen große Mengen also steht sie ja wieder mal die Frage wie ist denn das definiert also was ist denn groß im Verhältnis zu was den Befund bei Mengeneinheiten von irgendwelchen Datenmengen also,
wo fängt irgendwas an wo fängt man an zu zählen wie qualifiziert man denn das überhaupt gibt aber auf den Vorstoß der irgendwie sinnvoll erscheint oder gibt es eigentlich nur diese Formulierung.
Das ist sicherlich sowie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung Richtlinie wo ist auch hieß schwere Verbrechen und dann hast du halt in 31 Ländern 31 Interpretationen von large amounts von großen Mengen oder schweren Verbrechen.
Dann beschließe ich jetzt dass die EU-Kommission nur noch wirksame Gesetze erlassen darf.
Ja das wäre das wäre wünschen,
ja so ungefähr ist das aber ich glaube völlig unabhängig davon wie genau große Mengen definiert würde ist völlig klar dass es sich bei Wikipedia bei geht ab oder auch bei solchen Dingen wie,
Community Flicka selbstverständlich um große Mengen handelt das Problem ist aber die Kommission argumentiert halt immer naja,
Räder können ja so schwierig nicht sein und so teuer nicht sein weil die gibt's ja schon und dann sagen sie immer als Beispiel,
audible Magic das ist irgendwie die Musikerkennung Software die z.b. Soundcloud benutzt die kosten ja nur irgendwie 300 € im Monat also erstmal stimmt das nicht weil,
hier die tatsächlichen Kosten für ein Unternehmen auch bei Audible Magic hören sind aber davon mal abgesehen ordable Magic erkennt ja ausschließlich Musikaufnahmen.
Aber in dem Artikel 13 steht nicht,
dass die Plattform verhindern müssen das Musikaufnahmen hochgeladen werden sondern jegliche urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte.
Und das bedeutet diese Filter müssen nicht nur Musikaufnahmen erkennen können sondern auch z.b. die Übersetzung eines Textes kann nur über Rechtsverletzung sein oder.
Panoramafreiheit Bayern große Diskussion ein Gebäude kann urheberrechtlich geschützt sein.
Der alles möglich Kanone rechts bis ich Gezeiten ne also.
Also ja und es gibt es gibt diese Filter einfach nicht.
Darf ich kurz ein Gerät Schweiz in der ganzen Meta Debatte Urheberrecht gab es ja auch.
Maul wieder mal die Forderung die ich so nachvollziehen kann und ich wollte jetzt mal fragen ob man das vielleicht in dieser.
Diskussion auch noch mal vielleicht befeuern könnte,
dass diese Automatik des Urheberrechts so nach dem Motto wenn was geschaffen ist was und das Urheberrecht fallen könnte dann fällt es auch Automat,
darunter es muss also sozusagen nicht gemeldet registriert werden ja wenn man also quasi die das wieder rausholt bei,
eine Erkennung von Ulmer rechtlich geschützten Material wäre ja in dem Moment einfacher wo man eben auch verpflichten machen würde das urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material auch registriert werden muss um über rechtlich geschützt zu sein.
Also ich glaube schon dass das hilfreich wäre weil es in gewisser Weise unterscheiden könnte zwischen den.
Großen Mengen an Kommunikation die einfach an fällt dadurch dass Leute,
ja Dinge ins Netz stellen obwohl sie überhaupt kein Interesse daran haben die jemals irgendwie kommerziell verwerten und tatsächlich der professionellen Herstellung von Kulturgütern die irgendwie,
verkauft werden soll das geht aber leider derzeit nicht,
weil die Berner Übereinkunft die ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe also ein internationales Abkommen vorschreibt dass das Urheberrecht.
Automatisch gelten muss und das zu ändern.
Wäre extrem schwierig also dieses Grundprinzip kann man eigentlich nur ändern wenn sich diese vielen vielen Länder international darauf einigen was sicherlich ein längerer Prozess wäre es gibt Möglichkeiten trotzdem.
Zumindest ein paar Schritte in Richtung Registrierung von unberechtigten Werken für Unternehmen also z.b. dass man sagt bestimmte.
Rechtsdurchsetzung Mechanismen gelten nur für registrierte Werke das könnte man durchaus machen ich sehe aber noch ein anderes Problem.
Das vielleicht diese Registrierungs Debatte auch ein Stück weit.
Ja eigentlich ein Problem vorbeigeht weil also stimmt zwar dass das eine Erleichterung wäre aber selbst wenn es eine automatische Registrierung von urheberrechtlich geschützten Werken gelbe.
Wären die Upload Filter trotzdem schädlich und würden zwei overblocking führen weil es gibt ja Urheberrechts Schrank.
Also was ein Filter erkennen kann ist möglicherweise wenn er gut genug ist handelt es sich bei diesem Werk um ein Urheberrecht.
Oder nicht was er aber nicht erkennen kann ist handelt es sich bei diesem Werk um eine Parodie.
Um ein Zitat wurde das zu Bildungszwecken benutzt also all diese anderen Gründe die dazu führen können das urheberrechtlich geschützte Inhalte legal Verbände.
Und wenn man die Rechtsdurchsetzung im UEFA Rechtsbereich automatisiert so wie Thomas das gesagt hat dann fühlt das.
Das in der Praxis die Urheberrecht Schranken keine Rolle mehr spielen denn wenn ein Filter die nicht erkennen kann dann werden die Schranken 1.
Wird und leider ist es auch so im Urheberrecht dass Nutzer diese Schranken nicht einklagen können also sie beginnen zwar keine Urheberrecht.
Aber sie haben trotzdem kein positives Recht darauf dass ihre Inhalte online bleiben also in Seite 2 gelten die Community Standards oder sonst was.
Und wenn ich wenn ein legaler Inhalt von YouTube gelöscht wird dann habe ich keinen rechtlichen Anspruch darauf dass er wieder hochgeladen wird und das ändert sich durch den Artikel 13 natürlich auch.
Da gibt's noch einen anderen Aspekt der mich den Datenschutz Aspekt also ich brauche ja zum Filter wird immer darauf passieren dass er.
Einen entweder auf bestehenden geschützten bestand zurückgreifen kann eben mit der Erkennung hat und dann fließen dort alle Josef generierten Inhalte durch und werden im Zweifelsfall erkannt aber genau dieser.
Oft an zentralisierten Stelle aber weil es wird nicht jeder kleiner Plattformbetreiber in der Lage sein sein eigenen Abluftfilter zu bauen.
Gerade weil er ja auf dem Bestand geschützte Werke zurückgreifen muss und da hast du nicht nur irgendwie einen Flaschenhals wo ganz viel Kontrolle möglich gemacht wird weil da mal der gesamte Inhalt.
Durchläuft und manches halt eben auch durch den Filter im Filter hängen bleibt und nicht veröffentlicht wird aber du hast noch dazu Amanda,
Gardasee wir sind jetzt hat gesagt wir haben auch bei Magic und wir haben Content ID von Google also wenn.
Google Tim Person im Rechtsrahmen auf einmal in der schönen Situation wäre schon so ein fix und fertiges Filter Produkt zu haben.
Kann man ja ruhig auch gratis den ganzen Plattformen anbieten im Gegenzug gibt's halt eine komplette Erkennung des kulturellen wird der kulturellen Produktion in ganz Europa.
Ja klar also ich glaube letztenendes muss sich Google über dieses Gesetz.
Gewisser Weise freuen weil auf der einen Seite sind sie die einzigen die die Voraussetzungen bereits erfüllen weil der Anja diesen Filter schon also zumindest für Musik auch Google stehe wahrscheinlich vor dem Problem dass sie plötzlich irgendwie Filter entwickeln.
Die viel komplexere Arten von Uwe Rechtsverletzungen erkennen können aber sicherlich hätten sie den großen Vorteil dass sie Filter ist Service an.
Aldi kleinen Plattform die sich.
Können müssen im Zweifelsfall daneben ja Content-ID oder andere Filtersysteme von den größten Plattformen Einkauf.
Und ja also es kann sein dass das finanziell lukrativ ist also das lese und Dieselfilter so.
Natürlich auch sein so wie du sagst dass Sie gratis angeboten wird und einfach im Gegenzug Google eben Zugriff auf die Datenströme hat und genau aus diesem Grund.
Hat auch der Europäische Gerichtshof schon vor einigen Jahren in einem Urteil also Scarlett.
Urteil über ein Internet Service Provider in Zugangs Provider und im Urteil Netlog das war ein.
In beiden Fällen geurteilt die Verpflichtung zu einem solchen Filter der alle Inhalte überprüft die die User hochladen ist Grund rechtswidrig und verstößt unter anderem eben auch gegen das Grundrecht auf.
Also gut wir haben zwei dieser Themen durch gehandelt in der Richtlinie steht noch mehr.
Aber bevor wir uns jetzt in den in den Inhalten verlieren weil ich glaube die wichtigsten zwei Punkte haben wir mal dargelegt.
Was ist denn jetzt das Prozedere dieses Gesetz ist jetzt gerade noch im Parlament du bist da ganz nah dran über deine.
Berichterstattung das hast du bist für deine Faktion für die Grünen dort in den Verhandlungen beteiligt am kannst du deine Einschätzung geben.
Wie viel folgen diesem Prozess ist schon abgelaufen.
Und wie viel steht jetzt noch vor uns gerade mit Hinblick darauf dass wir ja im Mai 2019 Europawahlen haben und dass die Zeit davon.
Ja also im Europaparlament ist es so beim Leistungsschutzrecht das Parlament hat in der Vergangenheit immer gegen das.
Ganz viele Änderungsanträge zu dieser Richtlinie das live.
Wir haben allerdings das Problem dass auf der anderen Seite der Berichterstatter Axel Voss natürlich von der CDU ganz großer Fernseher.
Und auch in eintreffe Aussagen immer sagt das ist eine Priorität der hat jetzt aber das Problem das eigentlich keiner der Schattenberichterstatter ihm dabei zu stimmt also die Leute die auch.
Die Sozialdemokraten z.b. im Europaparlament verhandeln die sagen alle wir sind gegen das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Der einzige ja die einzige Möglichkeit für einen Kompromiss besteht in der sogenannten vermutungsregel das ist ein Vorschlag den die ehemalige Berichterstatterin also diese maltesische Abgeordnete Therese comodini gemacht.
Und die sagt na ja also es kann ja sein dass die Verlage,
ein Stück weit recht haben insofern das nicht immer nur kleine Textschnipsel übernommen werden sondern manche Nachrichtenportale übernehmen tatsächlich ganze Artikel oder große Ausschnitt.
Und dabei handelt es sich um Uwe Rechtsverletzung und möglicherweise ist es tatsächlich für die Verlage schwer dagegen vorzugehen weil.
Für jeden einzelnen Artikel erstmal nachweisen müssen dass der Urheber ihm die rechte übertragen hat und meist manchmal gibt's ja auch für einen Artikel mehrere Urheber und das ist vom Verwaltungsaufwand zu hoch.
Letzten Endes ist schwierig ist gegen solche Verletzung vorzugehen und.
Diese vermutungsregel ist also einfach eine Regelung die besagt wenn der Urheber dämlich Eck.
Spricht dann kann vom Gericht davon ausgegangen werden dass der Verlag die die Rechte hat und kann dann eben auch gegen solche UEFA recht.
Das finde ich auch in Ordnung ich glaube das wäre ein sinnvoller Kompromiss.
Auch um ein Stück weiter Kommission zu erlauben ihr Gesicht zu wahren und vielleicht eine Regelung einzuführen die den Verlagen was bringt.
Aber gleichzeitig eben die die also das Recht auf verlinkten im Internet unbedingt.
Eben nur die Rechtsdurchsetzung verbessert und nicht Dinge illegal macht die heute legal sind ja das wäre ein möglicher Ausweg.
Also beim Leistungsschutzrecht da haben wir zum zum Kompromiss am Tisch und das sieht so aus als könnte man sich darauf einigen dass das.
Also so weit sind wir noch nicht dass man sagen kann das wäre wahrscheinlich weil bisher werd's nicht hervorster gegen mit Händen und Füßen.
Und ich glaube was er er macht ist zu versuchen an den Schattenberichterstatter vorbeizugehen und einzelne Abgeordnete davon zu überzeugen dass Leistungsschutz.
Durchzubringen,
und das hat auch in manchen der Stellung nehmen den Ausschüsse geklappt also das dort teilweise mit der knappen Mehrheiten das Leistungsschutzrecht dann doch verteidigt wurde,
und insofern also das wäre denke ich ein sinnvoller Kompromiss,
aber ob das tatsächlich so kommt ich glaube das wird nur mit großen öffentlichen Druck möglich sein also ich glaube es wäre tatsächlich der beste Ausweg aus dieser Situation aber.
Der Druck auf die Abgeordneten,
auch von Verlagen die Springer ist einfach unglaublich groß also die hören natürlich solche solche emotionalen Argumente wie wenn es das Leistungsschutzrecht nicht gibt dann werden die Verlage finanziell untergehen,
und niemand will natürlich,
gerade vor den Europawahlen in der Presse so dastehen als hätte er sich gegen die Interessen der der freien Berichterstattung,
insofern am also ich hoffe dass es so kommt aber es ist alles andere als ausgemacht.
Gleichzeitig haben wir im Rat das Problem dass sich Deutschland dort überraschenderweise.
Im Wahlkampf plötzlich entschlossen hat jetzt doch für das Leistungsschutzrecht zu sein davor waren sie immer neutral weil sie gesagt haben ja im Vertrag steht wir wollen es Leistungsschutzrecht evaluieren,
und das lag halt auch einfach daran die CDU war für das Leistungsschutzrecht und die SPD war dagegen ja und dann kam Martin Schulz und wurde Kanzlerkandidat,
Martin Schulz ist gelernter Buchhändler hat sehr gute Kontakte zu den Verlagen und hat von Anfang an gesagt er ist für das Datenschutzrecht und dann hat Deutschland plötzlich seine.
Zu einem Rad geändert und ich glaube da kommt jetzt wirklich auf die SPD an also wenn es wirklich zu einer.
Große Koalition kommt müssen sich die Netzpolitiker in der SPD auf die Hinterbeine stellen und durchsetzen dass Deutschland sich gibt,
meine Hoffnung da sind doch eher begrenzt wer hat leider Martin Schulz nach wie vor in der SPD eine entscheidende Rolle zu spielen scheint.
Geht nicht auf mit der SPD ne es ist echt zum heulen tja Julia was ist langsam.
Was kann man denn jetzt noch tun also was könnte denn auch die unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer tun die sich hier an noch einbringen möchten.
Also ich glaube,
ganz klar ist die Rolle der neuen deutschen Bundesregierung im Rat wird extrem entscheidend sei nicht nur beim Leistungsschutzrecht sondern auch bei den Upload filtern,
und ich würde mir wünschen dass wenn ich mir anschaue wie viel Aufmerksamkeit im Moment die Diskussion über das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz bekommt das im Vergleich zu diesem Abluftfilter muss man ganz ehrlich sagen wirklich harmlos ist,
das,
diese Aufmerksamkeit mal die in der europäischen dem europäischen Vorschlag für den Upload findet wird und dass diese Diskussion auch miteinander verbunden.
Ich glaube das könnte unglaublich viel bringen also da wirklich einfach das Thema in die deutsche Öffentlichkeit zu bringen.
Ich glaube der ist aber auch das Branding irgendwie nicht besonders klug sind derzeit ne also Upload Filter das ist echt schon wieder so ein Schnarch Bezeichner.
Ja also ich glaube mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht durch das also dieses Branding Link steuertexte Link haben wir viele Leute darauf aufmerksam machen können.
Ja wie relevant das letzten Endes für für das Funktionieren des Internets,
und der ähnlich überzeugende Slogan für die Upload Filter fehlt noch reden von censorship machine aber es ist glaube ich noch nicht so,
deutlich was das bedeutet wie ist das vielleicht bei Sendling ist und ja das wäre schon wichtig,
was glaube ich was man noch tun kann ist es gibt eine ganze Reihe von konkreten Initiativen,
die versuchen darauf hinzuweisen also was eigentlich die negativen Auswirkungen dieses uploadfield als wären es gibt sicherlich irgendwie unter den Zuhörenden jede Menge software developer,
es gibt es koscher. EU,
es ist eine Initiative unter anderem von der Free Software Foundation Europe die halt erklären moment mal diese Upload Filter werden für freie Software Repositories die absolute Katastrophe der würden 40 irgendwelche Inhalte gelöscht werden,
in anderer Software verwendet werden und.
Plötzlich funktionieren irgendwelche Dinge nicht mehr weil ein Algorithmus welche ich erweise etwas als Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Das ist eine Initiative der man sich anschließen kann es gibt auch für Leute die selbst irgendwie kreativ tätig werden create refresh das ist eine.
Ja Initiative die einfach auch andere Stimmen aus der Konsumkultur zu Wort kommen lässt,
es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe von anderen Initiativen die halt versuchen aus dem Blickwinkel einer bestimmten Branche oder einer bestimmten eines bestimmten Betroffenen Kreises zu zeigen wie absurd das ganze ist,
im Parlament kann man im Moment sagen am wichtigsten sind die Mitglieder des Rechtsausschusses und der muss mal was sagen.
Ja meistens die der Sozialdemokraten weil,
bei der bei der EVB also den den konservativen ist schon relativ klar dass die wahrscheinlich,
am Ende mehr oder weniger gezogen werden ihren Berichterstatter zu folgen aber bei den Sozialdemokraten gibt große große Diskussionen und da wäre es wirklich wichtig die Abgeordneten zu kontaktieren,
also die Mitglieder des Rechtsausschusses kann man auch relativ.
Unproblematisch auf der Website des Europaparlaments nachschauen da gibt es auch die Telefonnummern von denen es gibt aber auch so Online-Tools mit denen man die.
Automatisch also kostenfrei anrufen kann es gibt z.b. safe-mail.net eine Initiative gegen Upload Filter von Pizza freedom wo man auch die die Abgeordneten bei anrufen kann.
Ja wir verlinken auch noch mal den Rechtsausschuss den Juri Ausschuss im Europaparlament mit allen seinen Mitgliedern.
Europaabgeordnete anrufen macht Spaß.
Man kann das irgendwie wunderbar so den normalen Büroöffnungszeiten machen geht sich auch immer in der Mittagspause aus.
Hilft auch wenn wir das vielleicht nicht nur alleine macht sondern mit einer anderen Person dann hat das auch irgendwie so ein Community Respekt und es kann ganz lustig sein.
Abgeordneten zu sprechen sind meistens spricht man nur mit ihren Assistentin Assistentin wobei das oft sogar sinnvoller ist weil die dann diejenigen sind die wirklich an den Themen arbeiten.
Alle Europaabgeordneten sind zu tief in diesen Themen drinnen für Julia und.
Auf jeden Fall wäre es jetzt sinnvoll da da anzurufen kannst du dann noch was über den Zeitplan sagen wann diese Abstimmungen alle sein werden.
Ja also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll jetzt in den nächsten Wochen anzurufen weil die Abstimmung ist aktuell für den März geplant,
allerdings ist es auch so also,
am Tag vor der Abstimmung kann man vielleicht noch jemanden überzeugen sein nein in ein Jahr zu ändern aber die Verhandlung passieren natürlich dazwischen und je mehr Informationen die Abgeordneten darüber haben,
warum diese ablauffilter schädlich sind oder warum die vermutungsregel viel sinnvoller ist für die verlagert das Leistungsschutzrecht,
das sind alles Dinge die muss man jetzt kommuni,
sofern also zwischen jetzt und März ist glaube ich die heiße Phase beim Europaparlament allerdings wurde die Abstimmung jetzt auch schon mehrere Male verschoben insofern kann durchaus sein dass auch noch mehr Zeit sein wird aber die sollte man sicherlich nicht ungetan verstreichen,
auch noch ein grundsätzliches Ding anrufen ist auf jeden Fall am besten weil man da,
also einfach in der Erinnerung bleibt aber manche Leute haben vielleicht Schwierigkeiten damit telefonieren und auch da,
eine E-Mail zuschicken ist weniger wirkungsvoll aber kostet natürlich auch wesentlich weniger Zeit und man kann die gleiche E-Mail an alle Abgeordneten des Rechtsausschusses schicken das heißt also wer partout,
nicht telefonieren will eine E-Mail ist besser als gar nichts insofern.
Ja aber dann wenigstens die Anrede noch adoptieren weil der Spamfilter vom Europaparlament ist ist auch eher ein Pitbull.
Stimmt also man sollte das schon sich die Mühe machen es möglich zu personalisieren auch weil teilweise nicht die gleichen Argumente von allen Fraktionen gleichermaßen wichtig genommen werden also,
die schädlichen Auswirkungen auf kleine Künstler,
oder die die menschenrechtlichen Probleme mit Filtern sind vielleicht für Sozialdemokraten interessanter die Tatsache dass mit den Filtern plötzlich alle Daten an Google weiter gegeben werden ist vielleicht für die Konservativen überzeugender.
An wir haben ja hier doch wahrscheinlich recht diverse auch Menschen die in Situationen sitzen die uns zuhören und was.
Man schauen dass ich irgendwie fragen muss es wieso gab es noch nicht zu diesem großen Aufschrei vergleichen wird das was jetzt gerade an an gesetzlichen Änderungen uns droht mit dem was 14. Dezember in den USA mit Netzwerk alität passiert ist.
Dieser Netz hat alle Tier Entscheidung in den USA.
Könnte schon wieder bald revidiert werden also es gibt jetzt schon irgendwie 40 Senatoren die das ganze aufheben wollen und es wäre.
Wir sprechen hier aber wenn dieses Europa gesetzt kommt von derselben Situation wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das sogar Jahre nachdem wir endlich irgendwie richtig festgestellt haben das war illegal gibt es immer noch in den meisten EU-Ländern eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Und genauso wird es auch hier sein wenn wir dieses Gesetz verabschieden dann haben wir Upload Filter die gelten dann für alle 31 Länder da wird nationale Gesetze geben und auch wenn wir dann irgendwann mal vom morgen Recht bekommen was ich glaube.
Wird noch mal ein ganz ein steiniger Kampf den wir 31 mal für müssen dass die nationalen Gesetze dann auch weg sind.
Also ich habe da eine Theorie so also warum das so schwierig ist warum es diesen Aufschrei noch nicht gegeben hat ich glaube der Vorteil,
bei der Netzneutralität Debatte in den USA war das ist ein ganz klares Datum gab wo die Entscheidung getroffen werden sollte und alle wussten jetzt ist es 11:55 Uhr jetzt müssen wir mobilisieren das hat auch funktioniert,
ja ich glaube die Strategie gerade von Herrn Voß ist die Abstimmung immer wieder zu verschieben,
also ursprünglich sollten wir in ich glaube im September oder so Abstimmung wurde jetzt schon fünf Mal verschoben und das zermürbt natürlich die die Zivilgesellschaft auch irgendwann weil,
die meisten einfach auf freiwilliger Basis arbeiten und man sich dann denkt okay wir haben so viele Eisen im vorher was ist jetzt gerade am dringendsten,
und man vielleicht fälschlicherweise denkt die ulverich Debatte die hat ja noch Zeit der Abstimmung Termin steht noch nicht fest nur das Problem ist.
Wenn es dann einmal soweit ist wird der abstimmungszeitung möglicherweise nur mit ganz kurze Vorwarnung festgelegt werden und dann kann es sein dass man plötzlich feststellt.
Oh verdammt die Zeit ist rum nächste Woche wird abgestimmt und dann ist es zu spät noch die große Mobilisierung zu starten also deshalb glaube ich das wichtigste was man machen kann ist das wirklich ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen wir müssen jetzt,
zu dem Thema die große Kampagne starten und nicht abwarten bis dann vielleicht abgestimmt wird oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Ja so ist es definitiv jetzt fünf vor Zwölf,
auf dieser Erde Strategie sollte man sich nicht einlassen ich man die Europawahlen sind eine harte Deadline und allzu nah an die Wahl wenn Sie das wahrscheinlich nicht heranrücken lassen weil das hilft auch der Bürgerrechtsbewegung wenn wenn die Abgeordneten wissen sie müssen sich,
der Wiederwahl stellen überlegen Sie vielleicht auch zwei mal irgendwie so ein Gesetz noch zu beschließen und muss auch einfach mal sagen das ganze ist nicht nur ein zivilgesellschaftliches Thema also ich würde mir auch wünschen dass ihr.
Wirtschaftsvertreter aktiver werden aber vor allem auch insgesamt Internetfirmen also die Wikipedia sollte hier eigentlich wieder ein Blackout organisieren ich finde das wäre angebracht.
Möglichst vielen Sprachversion weil das sind die ersten die davon betroffen sein werden und dann geht ab jede Art von Preisvergleichs,
vorn oder auch studieren Börsen wo man Bilder hochlädt wo man Videos hochlädt wo man Texte hochlädt also.
EBay also stell dir mal vor wenn ebay überprüfen müsste ob die Produktfotos die da jemand einstell-tool berechtigt geschickt.
Also im Grunde das können wir nur irgendwie dadurch abfangen dass die die Nase.
Den Schaden haben werden jetzt aufstehen und mal aufzeigen hey das bedeutet das für mich das bedeutet das für diese Webseite auf der du gerade bist,
und sowas koordiniert zu machen ist glaube ich der beste Weg aufzuzeigen.
Bullshit Gesetz dir das ist gerade im Hinblick auf die Upload Filter ist das,
darf ich deine fokussierte Kampagne drauf zu machen wäre am sinnvollsten das Leistungsschutzrecht das kann man mitnehmen das ist auch wichtig aber das mit den Upload filtern ermöglicht auch noch meine ganz eine andere Koalition.
Ja und zuckt brechen wir vielleicht.
Eine super Idee.
Also wenn wenn das irgendwie aufgegriffen wird so so eine Art koordinierten Blackout zu machen nicht nur von der Wikipedia sondern von allen,
im Prinzip Hosting-Provider in einem Plattform die davon betroffen sind die einfach nicht Google und Facebook sind das würde schon ganz,
ganz großen Eindruck machen und ich glaube dass wir auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Maßnahme die dann auch bei den Abgeordneten ankommt.
Ja also tut was Leute.
An die Website sind da ist Zimmer ist erklärt du dir das Büro ist glaube ich auch ein guter Anlaufpunkt um sich weiter zu informieren und auch um Antworten zu bekommen wenn jetzt noch irgendwelche Fragen offen geblieben sind.
Ja also auf Julia Räder. EU habe ich jeweils eine Übersichtsseite zu diesem wichtigsten Themen,
Leistungsschutzrecht Upload Filter gemacht die wir auch aktuell halten da updaten wie auch immer also wenn es tatsächlich einen neuen Termin für die Abstimmung gibt,
dann wird das sofort auf unserer Übersichtsseite gab der hättet und da kann man sich immer über den aktuellen Stand der Urheberrechtsreform informierende.
Du mir dann auch meine.
Gut.
Julia ist ja nur noch Indianer.
Also ein bisschen mehr 16 Monate.
Also also ein also 11 was noch garantiert ist sozusagen und dann bitte noch mal antreten in irgendeiner Form.
Also ich habe ja immer gesagt auch schon als wir auf dem Camp geredet haben mein Ziel ist nicht Berufs Politikerin zu werden sondern mein Ziel ist das Olive rechts.
Und also ich glaube wenn diese UEFA Rechtsreform abgeschlossen ist.
2019 woran ich immer noch glaube dann gibt's für mich eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt keinen großen Grund noch mal anzutreten weil das ist die größte Urheberrechtsreform seit 2000.
Und das bedeutet auch danach wird die Musik erstmal in den Mitgliedstaaten spielen weil die müssen dann alle diese Richtlinien ihr nationales Recht umgesetzt.
Und die EU wird danach wahrscheinlich wieder für 10 bis 15 Jahre keine größere über.
Wann gehen sofern Plan ich im Moment ihr nicht noch mal anzutreten sondern stattdessen eben dann dort tätig zu werden wo gerade das Urheberrecht.
Ja wo man am meisten erreichen kann in denen.
Kanzler wer gerade noch frei.
Ja ja das ist dann die Frage mit wem ne also ich glaube.
Ach Thomas macht bestimmt Mütze.
Ja also ich glaube die deutsche Politik ist im Moment wirklich fast so deprimierend wie die österreichische was man selten hat kann man eigentlich.
Zur Europapolitik ich sag's dir wenn die eigenen Zustände beschissen sind dann dann kann man freudig nach Europa blicken und vielleicht da irgendwie was verbessern.
Ja bis auf das Problem dass die Ratspräsidentschaft in der zweiten Jahreshälfte dann von Österreich geführt wird das heißt wir haben dann wahrscheinlich die österreichische Regierung am Tisch sitzen werden im Trilog das Urheberrecht verhandel.
AFK.
Yeah Demos in Wien.
Immerhin immerhin haben wir deine aktive Zivilgesellschaft auch wenn die Regierung.
Okay und kann kriegt man jetzt in dem Jahr noch eine Führung bei dir.
Ja klar also.
Besuch ist immer willkommen ich mache regelmäßig zu Besuchergruppen allerdings versuche ich die also damit nicht nur Deutschland ab.
Ich bin halt die einzige Vertreterin der Piratenpartei im Europaparlament es gibt aber in ganz vielen Ländern Piraten also jetzt.
Sind irgendwie in Tschechien die Piraten mit 10% ins Parlament eingezogen in Slowenien stehen wir so um die 3% also es gibt eigentlich im Moment,
viele europäische Länder die für die piratenfee interessanter sind als Deutschland und ich versuche natürlich auch diese und bis.
Mit der EU und dem Europaparlament vertraut zu machen weil die das einfach 2019 auch brauchen werden dieses Know-how und insofern also versuche ich nicht alle meine Besucherplätze.
An deutschen zu vergeben aber klar wenn man irgendwie Interesse hat auch vielleicht an so einem internationalen Besucher Austausch teilzunehmen könnt ihr euch gerne bei mir melden.
Noch ein Platz hältst du vielleicht mal für die Logbuch Netzpolitik Redaktion frei ich denk mal wenn der Linus wieder da ist und so dann sollten wir vielleicht mal das hörertreffen in Brüssel ausrufen und dann einfach mal klickt.
Dahin laufen uns mal sozusagen solange solange es noch steht.
Gerne ist mir ein großer Spaß also dann könnt ihr als Journalisten quasi auch ein paar Lobby Meetings vereinbaren.
Und erklären also was was für euch also wie wichtig für euch die UEFA Reform ist so als führendes Podcast Medium in Deutsch.
Perium Imperium.
Aber das bringt nicht so einer guten Idee es gibt für alle hören und Führer in Brüssel das netzpolitische Bier.
In Brüssel dass wir vielleicht meine Empfehlung also wir in Brüssel lebt und jetzt politisch interessiert ist sollte da auf jeden Fall mal vorbeischauen und sich mit der lokalen Community vernetzen.
Welcher Regelmäßigkeit hat das.
Keine also ist es so mehr oder weniger einmal im Monat vielleicht aber es wird meistens irgendwie an dem Tag gemacht wo es auch,
irgendeine Anhörung gibt oder irgendwas irgendeinen Grund weshalb nicht politisch interessierte Leute so aus der Community auch nach Brüssel reisen.
Insofern ist es nicht so ganz irgendwie jeder dritte Donnerstag im Monat oder so sondern Artrock ich weiß auch gar nicht wie man sich am besten darüber informieren kann wann das ist also wahrscheinlich bei edry ich kriege das immer irgendwie über die.
Bitte account.
Haben wir verlinken da was wo man sich informieren kann und an der Stelle Sauna mal erwähnt wer in Brüssel ist und dass der Zivilgesellschaft kommt kann immer bei Ihnen vorbei schauen.
European DigiRights ist so der Dachverband der Zivilgesellschaft impressum die haben aktuell auch eine Spendenkampagne auf ihrer Website die wir verlinken werden.
Idre ist eine ganz wichtige Organisation.
Annobon um überhaupt nicht nur eine Stimme Interesse zu haben sondern auch oft Augen und Ohren über ohne die kriegen wir viele Dinge erst gar nicht mit.
Und der deswegen auch da noch mal in den kauf dir ein Spendenkampagne.
Ja also wirklich da ist euer Geld gut aufgehoben es gibt eigentlich kaum eine NGO die mit so wenig Mitteln doch so viel erreicht weil letztenendes das ist wirklich ein.
Ja ein riesiges Sammelsurium an unterschiedlichen digitalen Rechte Themen die von edry bearbeitet werden und die einfach der in den Informationsfluss.
Auch zu zu den ganzen NGO.
Und da ist glaube ich also dann bringt jeder Euro wesentlich mehr als vielleicht bye bye,
vielen anderen Organisationen die einfach mit ganz anderen Größenordnungen und Spendenaufkommen arbeiten können als ebrietas.
Na gut dann such uns mal einen schönen Termin raus wann die Dinge mal alle wieder zusammen kommen könnten und dann können wir ja mal ein größeres happening draus machen ich hätte auf jeden Fall Spaß dran und.
Ansonsten weiß ich aber noch was wichtiges vergessen Thomas hast du noch was auf deiner Liste.
Abgesehen davon dass man es noch über 1000 Sachen reden könnte aber ich glaube da läuft uns jetzt gerade die Zeit auch oder ist es schon davon gelaufen.
So schon davon gelaufen wie es gäbe noch ne Latte an Team die jetzt auch noch bis zur Europawahl beschlossen werden müssen aber.
Darüber müssen wir an anderer Stelle reden aber wir versuchen noch irgendwie vielleicht so den Jena zu nutzen um mal an Europa Update zu geben gerade weil jetzt irgendwie so ja die Wahlen im Ausblick sind und jetzt wird noch ganz viel passieren.
Aber die wichtigsten zwei Themen haben wir mit Julia heute abgehandelt und wir werden wieder ganz viel verlinken.
Und wir bedanken uns jetzt aber erstmal für Julia für die Zeit und für die viele Arbeit die du da machst und und ich hoffe irgendwie doch noch das wird dich für eine zweite Amtsperiode begeistern können also dass wir zumindest.
Mein Neujahrswunsch.
Das muss ja ein Podcast.
Ja danke euch also wenn ihr mich überzeugen wollt dann müsst ihr wahrscheinlich dazu ja dazu beitragen Axel Forster weil zu helfen die UEFA Reform zu verzögern ich weiß aber nicht.
Im globalen Interesse Tennis Community ist aber ja ansonsten freue ich mich darauf wenn ihr wenn ihr mich in Brüssel besuchen kommt und da machen wir dann sicherlich auch noch mal ein Update für den.
Write super Julia vielen Dank.
Und vielen Dank hier an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer fürs zuhören und bis wieder einschalten und wir sagen einfach mal tschüss wa.
Tschüss bis bald.